Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with more news about the
NeverEnding quest to exonerate Islam of
responsibility for the crimes done in
its name and in accord with its
teachings the news is full these days of
stories about how everyone who knew the
latest Jihad attackers in New York and
Minnesota is shocked shocked that he
could have done such a thing if any of
this shock is sincere it is based on the
difference between how the Jihadi
behaved before he undertook his Jihad
and the violence he attempted but that
very difference may be why they opted to
commit Jihad violence to redeem
themselves after lives of sin and lack
of interest in Islam call it Redemptive
Jihad the New York Times reported
recently that dahir Adan who stabbed 10
people at a mall in St Cloud Minnesota
on September 18th 2016 while making
references to Allah seemed like a model
of assimilation not a violent jihadist
people who knew him and his family said
the son of Somali refugees he lived in
the United States most of his life did
well in school played Sports worked as a
security guard and took classes at a
local College Jama alamad a friend of
the family said he was a normal American
kid I can't see anyone more assimilated
than that guy a friend recalled he was
such a sweet humble guy and that's still
how I see him he was said the times a
quiet mild-mannered youth who was not
especially religious though also not an
atheist likewise akmed Khan rahami who
planted bombs in New York and New Jersey
on the same day September 28th 2016 he
ran a chicken joint in New Jersey the
times tells us that a friend recalled he
gave me free chicken he was always the
most friendly man you ever met according
to the times his other known Obsession
was souped up Honda Civics that he liked
to race neighbors described him as a
friendly car Enthusiast and were
surprised by the arrest he used to wear
western style clothing and gave and
customers said he gave little indication
of his Heritage he had Rifts with his
father who was more religious and
traditional his father was especially
displeased when Mr rahami had a daughter
with a high school girlfriend according
to friends now the times went on in
recent years though some friends noticed
a marked change in his personality and
religious devotion after what they
believed was a trip to Afghanistan where
he and his relatives are from he grew a
beard and exchanged his typical wardrobe
of t-shirts and sweatpants for
traditional Muslim Garb he began to pray
in the back of the store his previous
genial bearing turned more Stern and
there is the likely key as to why both
he and dadan Mild mannered friendly guys
embarked on the path to Jihad they may
have been trying to make up for previous
sinful activity including assimilation
into Western Moray which Hardline
Muslims consider to be sinful or simply
for a lack of interest in Islam and they
wanted to make up for it by doing a
great good deed the Hadith has has a
Muslim asking Muhammad instruct me as to
such a deed as equals Jihad and reward
Muhammad replied I do not find such a
deed the Quran teaches that Allah will
place a muslim's good deeds on one scale
and bad Deeds on the other and send them
to Paradise or Hell depending on which
scale weighs more a Muslim who's worried
about his eternal Destiny can decisively
tip those scales in his favor by waging
Jihad the deed that is greater than all
others he can thereby seize thean 's
promise of paradise For Those Who Kill
and are killed for Allah this will not
only make up for his sins or
indifference but will make him a hero to
numerous Muslims worldwide we've seen
this again and again after Jihad mass
murderer Muhammad lued buhel drove a
truck into a crowd in n France last July
murdering 84 people a cousin of his wife
wed hamu said buhel was not religious he
did not go to the mosque he did not pray
he did not observe Ramadan he drank
alcohol ate pork and took drugs this is
all forbidden under Islam he was not a
Muslim he beat his wife my cousin he was
a nasty piece of work now does being a
nasty piece of work really mean that
Buel was not a Muslim no if he really
didn't attend mosque did not pray did
not observed Ramadan drank alcohol ate
pork took drugs all that means is that
he was a bad Muslim he could at some
point have awakened and thought wait a
minute I'm headed for hell what great
deed can I perform that will outweigh
all my evil Deeds
the answer to that question of course is
Jihad according to Muhammad himself the
greatest of all deeds and that he beat
his wife was hardly a sign that he
wasn't a Muslim since the Quran actually
commands that women from whom men fear
Disobedience should be
beaten Redemptive Jihad Jihad says the
Quran will heal the breasts of folk who
are believers no more worrying about
whether one will spend eternity in
Paradise or Hell the previously sinful
or indifferent Muslim guarantees for
himself a place in paradise and that not
the blood of his Infidel victims is all
that matters I'm Robert
Spencer